the carolina panthers with the best
running back in football he reportedly
will be out four to six weeks with a
high ankle sprain here is christian
mccaffrey talking about his anticipated
absence and whether or not it will be
quite as long as
believed
yeah it sucks you know i mean to be 100
transparent anytime you get injured it's
it's a horrible thing you know you play
football to play not to sit out and
this is part of the game and it happens
but
you know i don't i don't believe in
coincidences i think everything happens
for a reason and
i think everything is perspective and
attitude and when you look at it you
know
you can
you can win or you learn and right now
is a learning experience for me you know
i've
prided myself on being on the field and
and freak accidents happen a lot
and this is one of them and if you look
around the league you know there's a lot
of guys who are who are down right now
but um i think the biggest thing you can
do right now is stay strong and and
fight through it you know they say four
to six weeks well that's a challenge to
me and
uh you know hopefully i can get back a
lot earlier than that but i'm gonna
attack this
uh just like i attack anything else and
you know go from there
i'm not going to take the bait christian
mccarthy i'm not going to do it i'm not
going to get into this spiritual
discussion of on one hand everything
happens for a reason versus calling it a
freak accident look the reality is once
you walk onto that football field you're
submitting to the possibility that a
freak accident is going to happen and
the hand of god is not reaching down
saying let's see who i'm going to mess
with today once you're out there it's
like placing a bet you're rolling the
dice maybe you get lucky and you walk
away unscathed maybe you don't but there
isn't some greater divine i said i
wasn't going to take the bait sharing
i'm taking it but this drives me crazy
there isn't some greater divine plan as
to who gets injured and who doesn't just
like when russell wilson said god made
him throw four interceptions in the nfc
championship game a few years ago or god
made them lose the super bowl to see how
he'd react
no
it's a sport it's a game we allow
ourselves to make it feel like it has
some greater significance but god is no
more involved in what happens to a
football player than he is in whether or
not a guy properly tabulates the numbers
on an accounting spreadsheet so look it
happens you get injured and now
christian mccaffrey's mindset is to come
back as quickly as he can period it's
part of football
it is part of football and this is how
tough he is mike it had it happened a
couple plays before the touchdown and he
tried to re-tape and even come back in
the game and
and obviously couldn't go but he started
50 consecutive games and i i don't know
why panthers fans are going to be
excited about this team now he was the
one thing you wanted to watch in a
panthers game and now he's gone
for at least a few weeks so i'm not sure
over the next two weeks four weeks six
weeks however long it is what panthers
fans have to hope for they only have two
other running backs on their 53-man
roster and mike davis has made 10 career
starts and he's certainly not christian
mccaffrey because nobody in the nfl is
christian mccaffrey he's the best
running back in football which is why
he's paid like it
yeah teddy bridgepart is going to find
out what it's like when there are no
longer extra safeties at the line of
scrimmage and teddy's been good but
again it's one thing to have christian
mccaffrey to open up your passing game
now it's going to be a greater challenge
for teddy bridgewater for a team that's
on two but they have not been bad
they've been competitive and both of
their losses have to be competitive for
however long christian mccaffrey is out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports